[Music]
under 40 like to have fun kids looking
good body
you're looking at it right here she
loves me unconditionally she wants to do
whatever it is I want to do
she's like say unconditional love I
think says it all
are you kidding me look at that face
perfect life partner Altos oh look a
perfect life so it's really just like
you know they got to be happy they got
the energetic got to be outgoing
so that's you come find me I don't know
I don't think I can
yep
someone who puts up with me easygoing
red hair light skin no I have to she's
standing behind no just someone who's
willing to listen and tell me when I'm
wrong and someone that I can listen to
what she's do
so that's that's the goal blonde hair
greenish blue eyes very nice like horses
nice body
all around good person perfect gentleman
or a nice guy adventurous - fun to be
with
[Music]
he's very kind he's generous he's very
loyal he's always been there for me
and he's just a very amazing person he's
very kind I don't know I just be just
kind of click and go he's played so well
my life partner is sitting right behind
me someone who supports they loves me
cares for me and is there even when I'm
not when I'm not present yes it be this
guy Chris
[Applause]
it's hard for you describe because like
I said I'm the quiet guy and he bounced
me out perfectly
just like I bounce it out and I don't
know I just you feel that way about
someone where
[Applause]
you handle the way I look at it is this
there's no one else that can really deal
with my [ __ ]
and I don't think there's anyone else
looking put with his [ __ ] and it
works out perfectly and that's that's it
for you pan your camera to the left she
is standing right there
she's loving caring responsible and I
love her so much she can
[Applause]
Oh where's she go
[Music]
because she makes me the best version of
myself
ah
my husband he's really skinny um really
funny and really sweet I love him more
than anything
she's really sweet and loving
well the foundation of my heart is to
have someone that's spiritually grounded
no matter what culture they come from
just so we can be unbalanced to support
each other this is all about balance and
harmony the vessel a persona
[Music]
Oh Johnny
Parmalee personae evolution mundo
so
one I mean it might sound weird but I
like one that actually likes to argue so
that way we can actually know each other
differences cuz I mean we're not gonna
argue that basically means you want to
submit everything I say doing this like
I like for you to tell me no sometimes
somebody who is open honest
and so for where
an attractive man
the most important thing I think is for
somebody
but I can get along
confidence and the best parts of me and
Reid for him sense of humor doesn't take
things too seriously and probably likes
the outdoors in the beach this soon uh
well I like her because she loves me for
who I am and I know it's kind of deep
and sappy but it's really true she likes
to do all the crazy things I want to do
in life traveling you know going and
visiting family when it's not convenient
and I don't know if she's spontaneous
and I think that's really cool and a
really important thing to have in a
relationship so a perfect light partner
pretty well pretty adventurous
you know understandable
consider it
and patience
kindly walk around the beach together
do so when you walk on the beaches yeah
someone where I could throw in the water
and be able to throw me back in
we'll always keep you in check you can
always
so when you can always rely on and
someone to just make you
kind of help you out in the in the
places where
you're not so great and hopefully you
build them up as
someone that I'm compatible with that
likes to have fun but has good values
love the outside has to be down for an
adventure
has to be unique or like to be like
everybody else and above all has to make
you as happy as you make her someone who
has similar to bleeps as mean in a sense
of their a realistic monogamy is I just
want something to be honest and open and
not someone who's is gonna and I don't
to be everyone relationship like that I
feel forced I don't think that happiness
can be for us and I don't think people
should say our relationship it's not
happy so I really want someone who has
equal understanding of what I need with
fading it would be best for us as a
couple and individual
okay I'm curious how realistic do you
think your noggin is I don't think it's
realistic at all I guess I mean it's
ideal my parents been married for 35
years so you think I'd say opposite but
I guess with just all this technology
and temptation today that it's not it's
not realistic I don't think it's natural
either it's not how it was you're made
to be so I think it's challenged but
yeah so I guess you the question of
describe your perfect life partner you
just don't put anything believe it I
mean I did lie I think we could have a
life partner and not like soul mate I
think a life partner I guess you're
asking what I'm looking for in a life
partner I feel like someone who's
equally concerned about my happiness as
I am there's
[Music]